most of NPR's fresh air and she's just
written a book about her favorite
interviews of actors writers artists and
musicians she speaks about that with
Frank Rich of the New York Times this is
just over an hour hello I'm Jennifer
Giunta Haussler from the Charles Simon
Centre for adult life and learning here
at the 92nd Street Y it's my pleasure to
welcome you to our interviewing the
interviewer series before I interview
our rather introduce our speakers I'd
like to extend our gratitude to Barnes &
Noble
for their sponsorship of this event and
they will also be in the adjacent hall
afterwards selling books I'd also like
to welcome c-span who is taping this
program for broadcast please write your
questions on cards and they'll be
collected by the ushers tonight we'll
have New York Times columnist and
associate editor Frank rich interviewing
Terry Gross mr. rich has had a long and
distinguished career at the New York
Times previously serving as op-ed
columnist senior writer for the New York
Times Magazine and theater critic he's
also the author of a collection of drama
reviews hot seat and a memoir ghost
light the program that Terry Gross hosts
on NPR fresh air is a Peabody
award-winning weekday magazine of
contemporary arts and issues and reaches
nearly four million people per week on
more than four hundred and fourteen
stations in the US as well as Europe and
Miss gross is often cited as one of our
country's best interviewers she's the
author of a new memoir I agree all I did
was ask is the title of her book
conversations with writers actors
musicians and artists and she'll be
available to sign books afterwards
please welcome Frank rich and Terry
Gross thank you
thank you
thank you I don't think I could be in a
worse position than having to interview
oh it needs to be I don't think I could
be in a worse position than having to
interview the best interviewer in
America so bear with me I just want to
say something before we start you know
last sunday frank rich's column was not
in the newspaper and you should know my
husband turns to me we open up the time
we really wanted to know what you had to
say about the election we open up the
paper you're not in it my husband says
to me I hope that's not because he's
busy preparing for the interview with
you I want to begin actually with a
quote from your wonderful book which is
as follows from the introduction privacy
was also a protective instinct for Jews
of my parents generation who lived
through the air of the Holocaust and the
post-war witch hunts and you talk about
how your parents don't like you to
reveal yourself at all and I assume
we're somewhat disconcerted by the
profession you went into but explain
there must be some psychological
connection or disconnection between that
kind of Jewish family upbringing and
what you ended up doing oh maybe you
know and and you notice on the air I'm
the one asking the questions not giving
the answers so you know it's easy it's
easy to kind of hide yourself in a way
but the fact that you would want to want
to go and and and reveal the secret
reveal the secrets of others yeah well
you know in some ways I think that has
less to do with like my parents and
their sense of privacy than it does with
like living books and things like that
and always wanting to know what's the
story behind the story what's happening
between the lines
and I think it's my own sense of privacy
my own sense of and I'm much different
than I used to be I used to be
compulsively afraid to reveal myself and
interviewed I'm no longer that way so I
don't mean to scare you
but there was a period where because I
was brought up to be so private and
because there was this thing of like you
don't you don't talk about negative
things in public that I was always
afraid that if I if I said something I'd
be betraying somebody and you know and
my father was in the labor movement
before I was born he was a you know in
the labor union in the garment industry
in the garment district and there was
always a sense to that you know that
people wouldn't under his in the labor
movement at least my mother felt that
way because they felt that people
wouldn't understand that unions had got
gotten this reputation of being more
corrupt and they wouldn't understand
how important the Union was at that time
and what it really did for for the
people you know in it and this would be
coming after the McCarthy era exactly
exactly you grew up in Brooklyn yeah
when did you discover the radio well I
always loved the radio but the radio
that I loved had nothing to do with the
kind of radio that I do now because I
grew up with top 40 I grew up in the 50s
and early 60s right I was born in 51 so
I grew up with Murray decay and the
swinging soiree and top 40 radio and you
know my idea of a great radio was when
Murray the K used to play a 45 and talk
over the instrumental and stop dead at
exactly the right part before the volkl
started that was my idea of what great
radio was so clearly that's not my
profession I don't think I heard an
interview on the radio until I was well
into my college years so as a kid were
roughly the same age I'm a couple of
years older you didn't listen to Jean
Shepard or any of this sort of great
Barry gray never listened to Jean
Shepard never listened to Barry gray so
given your interest in wanting to find
the story behind the story one what rat
you could have gone in was journalism
what did you just fall into radio or I
literally fell into radio my first
career was teaching junior high school
English eighth grade English in Buffalo
New York Steffes to inner city junior
high I was fired in six weeks that's how
good I was I was no taller than I am
today which is around five feet and I
was much younger than so I looked
younger than the students so you know so
it would always be chaos in the
classroom if they went to the classroom
usually they were in the hallway but
they'd be throwing around the
dictionaries and books in this and so a
real teacher would always walk in the
room and say to me where's the teacher
and I'd go I'm the T one day the
supervisor from the Board of Ed who is
coming to check me out he was there and
the students knew that like the official
person was there and on their way out
they overturned a bookcase and I think
that was like their verdict like she
can't control the class and I really
couldn't I had no idea how to be an
authority figure I am I am NOT an
authority figure I'm not saying I'm not
a Thorat ativ on something in terms of
like controlling behavior of other
people particularly when I was that
young I mean like a student would take
out a pocketknife and play with it just
to see what's she gonna do and I would
just stand there and I feel like this is
a really interesting movie but what's my
part what am I supposed to do and I had
no idea like I think they hadn't written
my part and I didn't know what it was
it's like the actor's nightmare so were
you devastated when you were fired oh I
was thrilled it was like yeah when can I
leave I knew I was mismatched for the
kids because they needed they needed
structure in their lives they comfort
they were poor they will come from very
chaotic neighborhoods and chaotic
backgrounds I was from this very
structured middle-class background and I
needed Anarchy I needed I needed that
and what I structure they needed was
something I was at that time of my life
incapable of providing and the anarchy I
needed was all wrong for their needs so
we were very mismatched I would have
quit except my mother's voice was
playing this tape loop in my head saying
don't be a quitter
how long was it after that
you got your first radio job um I
stumbled into radio not long after that
I knew I wanted to get involved in media
but I had no idea how to get into it so
I just kind of fell into it I know you
did some preliminary things in radio
before you ended up with the show that
we now know as fresh air
but how did just sort of skip through
some of that how did fresh air itself
come to be somewhat into your radio
career well I basically inherited fresh
air it existed a year or two before I
got there it was a three hour show five
days a week there was this kind of
freeform mix of interviews and at that
time before I got there mostly classical
music and I was hired to host and
produce it if so it was the staff was me
and a couple of volunteers who worked a
few hours a week and so the first thing
I did was have the classical music and I
start playing like jazz and blues and a
little bit of rock and the listeners
were so upset so it's largely a
classical music station and they call up
and go what's happening on my station
are you playing this rock music on my
station so so anyways I took over the
show and then Danny Miller our executive
producer came first as an intern in 1978
and that's when things started really
getting interesting I wanted it started
to really be fun because suddenly I had
this this kind of kindred spirit to work
with on the show a radio is a medium we
grew up in and live in the era of
television explain what makes radio in
your view a particularly commodious
medium for what you do and how would it
be changed it's evey well first of all
so if I was doing it on TV I'd be having
to go shopping a lot a real problem a
nice thing there's a lot of great things
about radio first of all I love music
and when I have on a musician I can play
their records you could argue well if it
was a TV show they could perform but a
lot of people probably wouldn't be
performing that easily or wouldn't be
willing to perform so and it's great to
just do like play music play favorite
records and so on
um I like to talk about ideas a lot and
it's hard I think I think it's harder on
television and radio to talk about ideas
because they're abstractions and
television people the television
producers I've known always want like a
visual like what's the image that goes
with that what what what's the visual
and a lot of things they don't have a
visual it's like it's in your mind
that's an idea or it's like personal
history and once you start putting like
the pictures up or something it gets a
little forced or phony so you can talk
about abstractions on the radio and also
I think people sometimes listen more
attentively on the radio because you're
in your car or you're preparing your
dinner or people's listen to the radio
when they're doing something else and
that sounds like that something else
makes it distracting but that's
something else is awesome it's often
something you're doing by rote and it
frees your mind to really be paying
attention on the visual part of it
you've written about and talked about
the fact that people are always startled
not always but often startled by what
you look like as opposed to some image
they have could you talk about that a
little bit yeah well first of all people
always think I'm gonna be tall because
if you fill up the speaker they figure
you might be able to fill up the room
and I'm not you know sometimes people
think you'll be taller than life like if
they like this I mean larger than life
if they like the show they might think
you're learn and I'm smaller than life
and also you know people people create
you in their mind and you're just not it
you're you know whether it's you're
better or worse than what they expected
or taller or shorter or thinner or a
fatter you're not it you're not right
and then they're stuck with this dilemma
the next time they listen to you who's
going to be in their mind is it going to
be the person who they created who's
always been there or is it going to be
this image of you that contradicts
everything that they've created in their
mind what about the fact that often your
subjects can't see you I mean I know
sometimes they I know they are with you
in Philadelphia in the studio but it
seems to me that that like Ted Koppel
often does this on Nightline many of
your interviews your your point of your
separated
and often unseen by your subject is that
how does that work does that work for
you or against you well sometimes I
think it works for me
particularly if I have to ask
challenging questions as I'm often in
the position of having to do I'm a bit
of a coward I'll confess to that and I
mean I'll ask anything to anyone
I'm more of a physical coward than an
intellectual coward but but it's much
easier to ask a challenging question to
someone when they can't give you a
withering look when they can't try to
look at you in such a kind of hostile
way or in such a in such a wounded way
that you feel like well how can I ask
this this next question so it's it's
it's just easier it's easier to just go
ahead and ask were you shy as a kid very
very and I still AM though not nearly as
much as I was because I'm so used to you
know meeting people and asking them
things but I'm much more shy and I'd use
the word insecure in my private life
than I am when you give me a microphone
like the personal insecurity is when I'm
doing a radio interview just kind of
fall away I'm there to do a job and I'm
gonna do it no matter what and I'm gonna
do the best that I can which might not
be good enough but I'm gonna do the best
that I can and any personal insecurities
I have irrelevant take away the studio
and the microphone put me out on the
street and I'm gonna be really different
in terms of those insecurities right
yeah oh they'll knit me in the behind
what what kind of interviews I'm gonna
go to some specific notorious ones a
little bit yes we inevitably have to get
to Bill O'Reilly but before our mutual
friend our mutual friends and fans but
before we get there to some of those
specifics what I know you you can tell
by listening to but it's also a fact
that you you prepare very very well and
and you do your homework but no matter
how much homework you do there must be
some interview subjects that make you
more nervous than others before you face
them
yes could you talk about that a bit well
the people who make me Merson most
nervous are the people who are my real
heroes like when I interviewed Stephen
Sondheim who is like to me like the
height of composing and lyric writing
and he hates being interviewed actually
detest being interviewed and I've
interviewed him I don't know three times
I think and because I loved his work so
much even though I know he hates being
interviewed and I know it's gonna be
difficult I apparently keep going back
for more and and then he also has this
way of when you ask a question if just
taking it apart and saying when you use
when you use the word music or when you
use the word Brown do you mean dark
brown or light brown or medium brown or
is it really purple and and and by this
time I'm just a nervous wreck because
you know so that's what makes me nervous
interviewing someone who's really a hero
now when you go back for more with
someone like Steve Sondheim do you get
more out of him do you keep doing it
because you think you'll be able to
excavate more from a great artist like
that
well like the last time I interviewed
him his the the the recorded version of
Saturday night which was his first
musical was released and I thought this
music is so rich rich I could just do
the whole interview just about these
songs so the fact that I interviewed him
before is irrelevant these songs are
worthy of an interview wanting
themselves who are the people who say no
to you well people who don't like being
interviewed I mean fewer more and more
people are willing to do our show now
because the show is better known but
often when people say no it's because
they're very very famous and they're
maybe doing either no interviews or one
or two interviews for like their new
movie or new record or whatever some
people you learn over the years say no
because they don't like being
interviewed they're not they're not
verbal they're not analytical about the
work nor are they anecdotal s and
they're not comfortable talking in front
of a microphone some people don't do
interviews us included because they're
sick
tired of themselves as interviewees
they've done so many and the questions
are so often the same that they they
just can't take it anymore have you
reached that position being on book tour
no I mean my book tour was two weeks
which was by book tour standards really
short mm-hmm and I mean I feel I do have
this kind of but enough about me type of
feeling but not to the point where it's
like oh I can't be interviewed again or
if you ask me one more question I'm
going to explode
and I might get really angry at the
interviewer or I might just reach a
state of despair I'm nowheres near that
what and there I'm sure there have been
but could you maybe give some examples
of interviews which may have going well
or not so well but where you could kick
yourself afterwards because you realize
only after the fact that the the one
question you most wanted the answer to
eluded you you just for whatever reason
it didn't come up or you didn't think of
it or well there are a lot of examples
of that but I can't think of one off the
top of my head though I will say that
one of the ways I avoid that is at the
end you know I'm in a studio during the
interview and there's usually a producer
and an associate producer in the control
room and then our executive producer
sometimes listening in in his office so
I almost always leave a few minutes at
the ends of the interview and the
producer the associate producer and the
executive producer if he's listening
have a chance to add questions that I
neglected to ask or to suggest
follow-ups to things so so there are
people who are there to think of the
things that I might not have thought of
which is great the interviews are never
live are they no when the show is local
we did alive and then when the show went
national for the first few months or
year the first half our interview was
live and then the second shorter
interview was pre-recorded but we found
for various reasons that it worked a lot
better if we did a longer interview you
know when the interview was a half hour
live I was used to doing hour-long
interviews on the local show and when
somebody gave me a long answer or an
answer was that was a dead end
I'd want to like grab them by the collar
and say give me a shorter answer the
clock is running can't you see we're
wasting time here and so now I can
record an hour and hour our producers
can edit the tape and it's so much
richer as a result of their excellent
editing one of the things you talk about
in the book is the people who filibuster
would I and while you can edit it down
later obviously given the way you work
there are particular awkward examples
you remember of people you had to
politely tell to shut the hell up in one
for well one of them was really silly I
was interviewing the the the person from
the Soviet he was the person who had
been the Soviet Union's leading American
expert the leading expert on America
your gr vltava and I was interviewing
him and his answers were long and
monotone and I finally said this and
this would really be a lot better if you
just give shorter answers make it more
conversational shorter answers and he
continued to give us long answers after
that then I said to him well you know
you work so closely with Mikhail
Gorbachev what kind of advice did you
give him about um about you know how to
talk to the press and he said I always
said to him mr. Gorbachev give shorter
answers let's let's go down this sort of
rogues gallery of people who walked out
on you now I know where any these people
physically in the room when they walked
out and you has always been them no
experiences it's always a long distance
when they walk out it's an interest this
is a short list I have that you can add
to it Monica Lewinsky yes
Bill O'Reilly I can see how they might
be connected lately we can see how they
might be connected Lou Reed yes and and
Peter Boyle of all people maybe there's
some others too what are they yeah
anyway yon winter yeah say Faye Dunaway
a new yawn winner
when're what what got yon winner going
oh well you know I had written I had
read um Robert Draper's book about the
history of rolling stone mm-hm
and in it he said that when yon winter
started because he had to convince
advertisers to buy into this magazine
and because the magazine didn't really
exist yet he made that up this list of
subscribers and and I thought well that
was really clever you know yeah you
gotta get your foot in the door somehow
and and so I asked him about that and
then I asked him also about and I'd read
this someplace that one of the reasons
why he wanted to start rolling stone so
he could get to meet John Lennon and I
thought well yeah that's as good a
reason as any right but I think he took
offense of those questions and kind of
ended the interview pretty quickly
what Monica Lewinsky you've said you
review interviewed somewhat reluctantly
yes explain that and explain her
premature departure yes well I was
reluctant to interview her for a couple
of reasons first of all I didn't want to
carry on the work of the special
prosecutor and why would she answer my
questions I mean I didn't have the power
to put her in jail he did and also when
sex is at the center of the story as it
was in her case where is the line
between journalism and voyeurism it's a
hard line to walk and I didn't
particularly feel like walking it until
her book publicist called up after her
memoir was published and said how'd you
like to interview her and then you know
I wasn't sure so I mean I sat down with
the producers
we really had a long talk about whether
we should do her or not and the reasons
not to do her were the ones I just
mentioned the reasons to do her was that
we agreed it would probably be
interesting and then we thought how are
we gonna feel like if another NPR show
does her instead we'll feel really bad
so ok do any of these people ever
subsequently apologize to you or do you
ever hear from them again um no no I'm
not sure they owe me an apology cuz in
my mind in their mind I probably owe
them an apology and with Monica Lewinsky
I I I don't think she owed me an apology
I mean I I was asking her questions like
you say in your book that the first time
you engaged in oral sex the president
was on
phone and and then and then I said and
yet yet you also said that you know you
felt you were clicking on an incredible
level like how can that be so I mean in
all honesty who wouldn't walk out but
that was why I was so reluctant to do
the interview in the first place and in
fact this was the only time in my career
when I actually bracketed the interview
with an essay in which I said I thought
her walking out was a fitting end to an
interview that both the interviewer and
interviewee was so reluctant
participating in mm-hmm
are there any questions in your mind
that are off limits or when you sit down
to prepare addition to the research and
the reading do you let your mind wander
very freely in terms of figuring out
what you're gonna ask yeah I mean I'll
basically ask anything to anyone within
the realm of you know discretion and
good taste whatever that is that's so
subjective if it seems to relate to who
they are like I won't just ask anybody
about their sex life or their sexual
orientation
however if somebody eats work their
memoir their play their music their
activism whatever relates to that then
that's gonna be the subject of the
conversation and and I will go as far as
I think they are comfortable going
within the limits of what I can say on
the radio which is becoming more and
more vague and unclear yes in this new
FCC era but but I will also tell people
before the interview starts that if I
ask them anything too personal that they
should let me know and I'll move on to
something else
remember we're pre recording and editing
the interviews so they have they are
able to tell me off mic that something
is too personal
and I will know you know to to withdraw
that that question and move on could you
walk through a bit the the gene Simmons
for those who don't know gene Simmons of
kiss very famous interview that you
conducted where he was essentially
trying to sexually taunt you it's it's
it's in here but I've talked talked a
bit about it and what went through your
mind and how that played out and did you
learn anything from it well for any
listeners who who any listener so used
to listeners for anybody who doesn't
know a kiss there are heavy there I
think of them as a heavy metal band for
preteens because that's I think
basically what they were when they
started in the 70s and you know they
paint their faces black and white and
dress in full heavy-metal regalia and
you know so I wanted to talk with him
you know in part about what it's like
for him now that he's in his mid-50s to
still be like strapping on the cot piece
for concerts doing the whole God of
Thunder bit and his attitude was he
never met me or heard the show and this
was a long distance and we didn't know
what I look like but his stereotype of
NPR I think was this kind of like
pretentious elitist stuffy program and
so I think he kind of wanted to get my
goat in a way but he was saying things
to me like I'm afraid the message is if
you want to welcome me with open arms
you'll also have to welcome me with open
legs you hear something that juvenile
and bright and well continue the story
well there's an interviewer you know I
have to ask myself when somebody is
getting increasingly obnoxious like that
what do you say do you do you act like
you're the kindergarten teacher and say
now mr. Simmons if we can't speak a
little more politely we'll have to end
or I have to send you to the corner you
know or do I act like well this is this
is just an interview and I'm gonna bring
it back to the subject and just ignore
what he said and go on and say in your
second album
or do I just say what I'm really
thinking which is like that's really
obnoxious you know is this is this the
only way you can talk to a woman is to
do that shtick which is what I said and
I figured you know I might as well just
stay what I'm thinking what possessed
you
explain what possessed you to interview
Bill O'Reilly well we we had had on Al
Franken after his book lies and the
lying liars who tell them a fair and
balanced look at the write was published
and I should say Al Franken has been on
our show many times since around
nineteen seventy eight or nine I've been
a fan of Al Franken's since his early
days in the Saturday Night Live era a
fan of his writing a fan of him as a
performer and so you know when Al
Franken has something new we usually
invite him up in a show because he's
incredibly funny he's talented he's a
great guest he had on this new book it
was funny satirical look at the write we
had him on a whole chapters devoted to
O'Reilly FoxNews is implicated in the
fair and balanced subtitle so we thought
it's only fair to have on Bill O'Reilly
and you know so we invited Bill O'Reilly
on to coincide with the publication of
his book a few weeks after the
publication of Al Franken's and of
course he stormed off now afterwards two
things happened one was as the New York
Times now has a public editor or NPR now
has an ombudsman and if memory serves he
criticized you but I never understood
what the art what his argument was what
was that about well he thought you know
I Riley said when he walked out on me Oh
Riley said to me you gave you know you
gave an easy ride to Al Franken you
didn't treat him this way because I was
asking O'Reilly challenging questions
first of all I brought up some of the
things I'll Franken said about him in
his book about how he had been less than
completely honest about his own
background O'Reilly will argue with that
and that's why we had him on so he could
take issue with whatever he wanted to
write so so I was asking him some
challenging questions just basically
repeating some things I'll Frank and
said quoting from the book and saying
you know tell us your version and then
also I wanted to know whether a riley
used his microphone and his power for
score settling for example he ends his
show every night with the most
ridiculous item of the day it's called
and I think we've both
the honor of being yes are the most
ridiculous antics and offer the person
on the most ridiculous item of the day
the person who he talks about in this
little mini editorial is somebody who
has criticized Bill O'Reilly and he has
a talking points thing at the beginning
or is also an editorial and sometimes
that's though not as frequently as the
most ridiculous item about somebody who
has said something negative about
O'Reilly so it's I I wanted to know if
he did that to have a chilling effect so
that people would be perhaps afraid to
say anything negative about him or
whether it was his way to get even and
it seems to me a fair question because
after all he is a very powerful man he
prides himself rightfully so on asking
very tough questions and you know I'm
never backing down and therefore I
thought that it would be fine to ask him
some challenging questions after all
when you don't do when one doesn't come
on O'Reilly show O'Reilly calls you a
coward his standard phrase is he's
cowering under his desk he's afraid to
be a guest on the show so I figured well
wait this is this is pretty pretty mild
by O'Reilly standards so when he accused
me of throwing every defamation at the
book in the book at him and treating him
unfairly I was shocked and I haven't
answered your question about the
Ombudsman I'm sorry I feel like to set
the scene no it's such rich material no
go right ahead my question
so the Ombudsman what was his point his
point was that that O'Reilly was right
that I did do very two different kinds
of interviews I gave a friendlier
interview to Franken and a more
challenging interview to O'Reilly and
that that seemed unfair and my view of
that is to quote somebody who I think
Bill O'Reilly respects Bill O'Reilly
[Laughter]
O'Reilly was once asked by one of his
viewers in an email that he read on the
air why did you treat so-and-so this way
and yet you treat it so and so that way
I figured who the person in question was
and he said different interviews demand
different strategies well I agree and
and you know the way you interview a
satirist like Al Franken and this was
before air America was before he had a
daily program himself is different from
the way you interview Bill O'Reilly they
are different people they come at their
jobs differently and therefore the
questions should be different obviously
I agree but then you went on a Riley
show yes
what was that an out-of-body experience
sir well to embody because then I got to
see it afterwards it was interesting you
know I was wondering like what would he
ask me what would I say about the
interview what I think about the
interview there's one thing in common
that my interview with him and his
interview with me had in common which is
they were both about him everything he
asked me was about my interview with him
and how I treated him unfairly and how
the Ombudsman even said I was unfair and
everything and of course one of the
things he criticized me for he worked
out of me was that he said I didn't ask
him one question about his book which of
course was untrue I asked do I even read
from excerpts of his book but the only
question he asked me about my book and
it was in your book you don't mention
the Ombudsman what he said not that I
cared whether he asked me about the book
or not I mean it's fine with me it's
fine that he did a book interview that
wasn't about my book that was fine with
me but I just thought I'd mention that
now do you think just for irony sake do
you feel compelled to invite him back to
discuss this new book The O'Reilly
Factor for kids
no we haven't invited him on for that um
going back to this sort of general issue
of young do you have complete editorial
freedom does NPR in any form ever tell
you what you should or shouldn't do
no though we we sometimes call we
sometimes call
producers or editors who we particularly
like and and and and trust at NPR and
and just say you know we're just really
confused about something this is such a
gray area you know talk it through with
us so we'll go to them for guidance when
we feel some guidance would be or just
like another brains I think a three
would be really handy but but they don't
they don't they're not a part of our
regular editorial process because see
they distribute our show our show is
produced at WHYY in Philadelphia and NPR
distributes the show but NPR does not
produce the show right but the whole
Gestalt of NPR how do you feel and
because it is the environment in which
yeah sure broadcast how do you feel it's
changed if it all over the year since
since you began began this what what do
you feel is this is the state of NPR in
a sense right now well in terms of
program and I think in some ways NPR is
more important than ever and I say that
from i watch a lot of like the cable
talk shows and I find them really
interesting I find them really valuable
to watch at the same time it's on a lot
of the shows it's hard to get a whole
paragraph in it's hard to even get a
sentence in as an answer and like the
news what started off at CNN it's like a
news network it's more of talk shows now
and I think NPR's news coverage and
interviews were you there's actually
time to develop a story there's time for
somebody to give an answer it's so
important now and also on the radio you
know the radio environment has so
changed just about every station it
seems is owned by one of the big chains
now and so there's there's this
homogeneity that is setting in or that
has set in Clear Channel so different
what we grew up exactly exactly where
you know that we're different records
were hits in different regions and so on
I mean that
has really changed and so so I think I
think NPR's is really important do you
think it's fair that when people on the
right try to say well Fox is fair and
valves but the but liberals have NPR
that you that NPR has been sort of
politicized for reasons that may or may
not having to do with NPR in in the
current sort of culture war what do you
make of that I don't think that's fair
and I think that I think that for some
conservatives not not all of them under
speaking of some conservatives that the
absence of a conservative agenda reads
to them as a liberal agenda mm-hmm that
if you're not on their page with their
talking points therefore you're liberal
I think that NPR is in fact very fair
and very balanced and very diligent in
its reporting and in and its interview
shows as well now we on our show do a
lot of arts coverage and as well as
issue and political coverage and even
the arts that seem to have become loaded
now and politicized in a way they
weren't before give an example of that
where do you see that where do we see
that well first of all a lot of actors
have become activists away in a way they
hadn't before and there's a kind of they
are more engaged with the political
process and sometimes wanted to talk
more about it but also you know like the
FCC for instance is is taking a much
more hard-hitting approach on the
language you can use so if we're doing a
reading I mean we have Sweeney Todd as a
favorite at fresh air particularly among
Danny Miller the executive producer and
myself so with every opportunity we get
we we play something from that on the
show and there's a line from the track
that's called epiphany that has the word
shift I don't know this is on c-span -
I'm not sure if we can say that or not
it's the four-letter word for
extra mint that starts with the SH yes
went away bleep away so what's it's
capable it's probably okay but whatever
so we had a call our lawyer we've always
played that but now we have to call our
lawyer and say is it okay to play this
on the air and this was this was
actually a few months ago and things
were so unclear about where the line is
now that we instead of bleeping it we
reversed it so it was like that word
backwards so so it's like there and not
there it's not being said but it said
it's very it's sort of the same chilling
effect is with this hoo-hah last week
about Saving Private Ryan all these
stations that refuse to right right and
and in in the lines it's just very
unclear now what what you can say and
what you can and yeah um oh I'll say
something else about arts cover right
the arts I'm gonna quote something from
Isaac Bashevis singer he once said in an
interview with the journalist and
professor Helen Benedict she had asked
him why some of his characters are
grotesque and he said when you're with
people you're like another person but
when you come home you're alone you take
off your clothes you may have passions
of which you are ashamed you may shock
yourself and I think that is really true
and I think that is exactly the
territory that a lot of literature and
movies and theater is about that part of
yourself that you're uncomfortable with
that you're maybe even ashamed of or
afraid of or troubled by we all have
that it's something we don't necessarily
confess to or admit to but artists many
artists go there
they're almost are appointed
representatives are delegates in going
to that territory that we can't talk
about because it's too embarrassing or
frightening and so when you talk about
this territory with artists some people
can be very offended and think the
says this is going too far feel this is
this is this is too sexy or this is two
irreverent or two you know it violates
something but that's what our does often
and and so so that sometimes the
territory that we end up talking about
on the show not with four-letter words
right but some people might be disturbed
by that or they might find it you know
that it goes against their morals or
principles or whatever but again that's
what the arts is sometimes about not
always but sometimes of course and only
as conversely do you get any sense in
some cases you're reaching people who
who might not be the obvious audience
for a great say American writer who
deals with difficult things that you're
turning people on do it do you have any
sense that that you're reaching young
people or people and dare I say in the
red states that may have not may not
have waiting Richard Pricer absolutely
and we hear from people like that all
the time and who say you know I I live
in a small town I'm you know there
aren't many say gay people here so I
really appreciate the gay writers you
have on the show or you know I really
like the way you talk about religion on
the show because we talk about religion
a lot on the show but we don't talk
about religion in a way of trying to
convert our listeners to any one point
of view we talk about religion in a way
of that there are there are several
different religions there are several
different paths to making sense of the
world to making sense of our place in
the world of the universe what are these
different paths and for the people who
are most in the know the clergy and the
scholars what can they tell us about
what they've learned how do they wrestle
with the major ideas of our time how do
they wrestle with life and death how do
they soothe people about death that's
how we talk about religion although now
we've been also talking about it in a
more politicized way but anyway so a lot
of people respond
to this and say it's you know I so
relate to that I live I live in a place
where bla bla bla bla bla and my
approach to religion it's hard to find
people who are like-minded or whatever
so people really appreciate this
appreciate the coverage of the arts and
again getting back to we're saying one
of our goals is to introduce the great
writers of our time who don't aren't
necessarily the people with the biggest
audiences of our time to the people who
would love their work if only they knew
about it mm-hmm let me ask you just a
couple of questions related to this
before I go to the questions from the
audience
what is leaving for a second leaving the
culture wars aside American culture
culture itself that you're talking about
goes through cycles do you feel this is
a good period for American culture or
not what kind of period are we in do you
think well I I've never seen a period
where culture is as divided as it is
we're like Sean Penn is in a movie and
there's almost you know this buzz like
don't see the movie because Sean Penn
went to Iraq you know and I I I just
can't remember that that kind of
absolutely nice it's like the when we
were little kids during the McCarthy era
maybe it was well I was too little to
really know it's to me too but yeah it
seems like it seems like it's but it
seems like that's what it was another
difference is I can think well the 60s
must have been like this but in the
sixties the counterculture had its
culture and the mainstream culture had
its culture and then eventually the two
kind of met someplace but the
counterculture wasn't much into the
mainstream culture but now there isn't a
counterculture per se like that instead
there's a fragmented culture there's
there's blogs and websites and cable TV
and independent presses and
do-it-yourself recording and everything
so things are totally fragmented but
there isn't that sense of a unified
counterculture and I think that's
perhaps part of the reason why the
mainstream culture is so divided I agree
with you if you had to maybe it's hard
to think of these things on the spot
but if there are a couple of artists you
might mention in any field that don't
have a large audience that are not brand
names that you particular fans of that
you might just mention oh sure
well in terms of writers I particularly
like I'll mention Richard Price and and
and Scott Spencer
in terms of musicians Richard Thompson
as a favorite in terms of singer
songwriters I'll mention a couple of
people who actually wrote our theme Jill
Forester and and and where am I gonna
Phillips last name Johnston yes Luke
Johnson they're both they're wonderful
they're just like wonderful composers
Dunn Byron yeah as a clarinetist and
composer just just terrific great well
let's see what I'm in a slightly sense
of the language on this one would you
consider interviewing President Bush I
would love to interview President Bush I
don't think he's coming on fresh air any
time in the near future
have you ever had any member of the Bush
family like Barbara when she was
promoting her book yes we had on Barbara
and how did that go it was okay I don't
really remember much about it that's not
meant to be a comment on Barbara Bush
how many people helped you do research
on the folks who interview who chooses
the people how long ahead do you have to
ask a person to be on the show let me
ask a subsidiary question and what do
you do about because the show does have
such a reach there must also be people
who are constantly conniving to get on
the show and asking the show and how do
you turn them away and how do you deal
with that well there are three interview
producers on the show who who find the
gas and spend their days going through
reams of material you know we have a
book producer who also handles a lot of
issues we have a movie and TV and pop
culture producer who who also you know
strays to issues when you know first
person issues and we have someone who's
devoted to
mostly issues you know it's it Monique
Nazareth Aimee salad and and and and
Naomi person and they spend their days
just going through this stuff as well as
like producing the interviews after
they're recorded and and and saying no
to a lot of people who call because
their phones don't stop ringing and they
often pre-interview gasps to find like
who's gonna be interesting who tell
who's gonna tell us something that we
don't already know and who's going to be
articulate and funny and concise and so
it's it's it's it's you have to jump
through a lot of Hoops usually to get on
and and then there's also that's just
part of the staff there's a researcher
who with the guidance of the producer
finds me the materials I have to read or
listen to or watch there's a couple of
associate producers who edit the tape we
have a director and our executive
producer so just I think because a lot
of people like like the whole idea
process right now is you're ending your
book tour and and what interviews how
far in advance now are you looking at
interviews what weeks months in terms of
the actual planning and booking at this
point uh well usually like the people in
the movies we booked pretty far in
advance because they have a 24 to 48
hour window when you can record them and
you have to do it then and you have to
schedule maybe like three weeks in
advance authors we sometimes schedule
like three weeks in advance sometimes we
schedule a day in advance issues we
sometimes schedule a day in advance so
it really varies some some of the
calendars bucked up away in advance some
of it is booked up like the day before
and it remains fluid so you can segment
them yes what do you do with show
business people particularly people in
the movie and television business who
because they do do that 48 hours of just
doing 75 interviews to keep them from
just giving you the same pad rehearsed
answers yeah well I wish I could say
here's how I do it and it works and and
sometimes I know I'm getting the Pat
answers in fact sometimes I think
there's almost no way around it in part
because there's certain questions I
really want
because I want to talk about you know
who they are in the story of their life
and it requires a asking certain
questions and unless they rewrite their
life the answer is the same as it was
last year when they were asked that
question so so you you have to you have
to accept the fact that sometimes you're
gonna get the same answers because it's
the only have one life but my approach
isn't to ask like the novelty question
the oddity question as much as it is to
try to go deeper hopefully I mean this
is the ambition not necessarily what I
achieve but to go to deeper than the
previous interviews have to like use the
the answers from the previous interview
as the basis of the question so so the
follow-up hopefully takes it to the next
step that's the goal penetrate exactly
off the top of your head who surprised
you the most and of interview subjects
are there some that come to mind where
you got someone totally different from
what you would expect it going in yes
I'm just gonna draw a blank probably but
I mean that does happen okay um does
anyone ever get paid on your show for
you to interview the only people who we
pay on the show or if somebody performs
like if a musician does a concert we'll
pay them we don't pay for interviews do
you have any tips for composing great
questions no one care about who somebody
is that's I mean I think that's the main
thing you know I think we've all anyone
who's been interviewed knows what it's
like to be interviewed by somebody who
doesn't know who you are and doesn't
really care either and then you have
this feeling like well you don't care so
why should I tell you and and and if
it's a print reporter then you also feel
you don't know you don't care you're not
gonna get it and and you might not get
it right and then you become afraid
afraid to tell them things about
yourself that are personal because you
feel like it's gonna get misinterpreted
and and once something's in print you
never get it back again
aside from Bill O'Reilly are there any
interviewers that you admire any of the
competition Utes
well I mean O'Reilly good at what he
does you know give him that but if do
when you are are there people there's a
lot of people I admire I mean some of
them you know a lot of them at NPR I
mean like Scott Simon I think it can be
a particularly empathic or empathetic
I'm not sure which the word is
interviewer I think Ira Glass is
extraordinary and getting to people to
talk in just the most conversational way
cuz that's how he is
I used to watch Dick Cavett a lot when
he had his PBS show and he had this way
he was just totally disarming like he'd
make a comment that seemed very both
insightful but also off-the-wall and
he'd say I don't know what the question
is and watching him do that just kind of
freed me up I thought if he could do
that I can do that too I could just say
what's on my mind even if I don't know
what the question is I wouldn't describe
him as its head Coble I think Ted
Koppel's looks really great at both
being very fair but not letting people
get away with anything and and he'll
just keep going on until you give him an
answer because it make you crazy to see
someone good like Coble do the same
person that you've done and you're
comparing what you've done to what he's
doing or not oh sure well that's you
know there's times when I almost protect
myself when sometimes when I've
interviewed somebody and then I see that
they're on another show I will just turn
it off because I think if they ask
something that I should have asked and
did and didn't it will just be too
painful so I just like go someplace else
now I know he's probably not I mean he
has an interview where of sorts but it's
a true that you listen to Howard Stern
oh sure I mean not not not as much as I
used to because I had a long commute and
I know just a few minutes away from
where I work so I don't you know I'm
going back and forth between Morning
Edition and and Howard Stern and a
couple of other things I'm checking out
in the morning I have very mixed
feelings about Howard Stern I don't like
the Freak Show part of Howard Stern I
don't like the the kind of breast size
penis size part of Howard Stern I don't
like you know I think part of his show
really has become this freak show where
where people are are on because there's
because they have a serious problem
because you can make fun of them or
because they're a stripper or whatever
however I think he's very gifted at in
in this way that's similar and different
from Lenny Bruce just in the sense that
he can just like riff off something
whether it's something in the news or
office gossip and make it so interesting
that everybody else wants to hear it and
he's turned his entire staff into a cast
of characters that you want to know
what's going on in their lives you want
to know what the gossip in their lives
is and they're all really good talkers
and I think he's really very gifted if
you could interview anyone from history
who would it be and why well I you might
you might enjoy this serious interview
anyone in history it would be the great
songwriters I'd have them at the piano
playing their songs as I talked to them
so it would be Rodgers and Hart and the
Gershwins and Harold Arlen and decent
Schwartz and you know riffing Berlin and
take me with you in high school you feel
that a questionnaire and said you wanted
to be a lyricist exactly and was it were
you already interested in that music or
was it rock and roll or what well um I
don't know if you went through this did
you grow you grow up in Washington I did
I don't know if they had this in
Washington in New York and some people
in the audience might remember this at
least in schools in Brooklyn I had
something called sing I know of it you
know and it is basically like an
extended sketch that you would do at the
end of the year and you'd write a story
and it would be a music so for the music
you would take songs from a current or
recent Broadway show and write your own
lyrics and I was one of the lyricist for
sing and I loved it I just loved it and
I thought wouldn't it be extraordinary
if I could like do this in life that's
great did you go to theater as a kid did
you go see musicals and not a lot like
maybe you know once a year or so my
parents would take me to see a musical
not not that much but but i but I still
loved you know I still love Broadway
music how much of the interview of an
interview is pre-planned and how
spontaneous it's a kind of mix of the
two you know I go in there with my
outline I have questions that are
written in a narrative order because I
think I think an interview isn't a
questionnaire and particularly on the
radio when the interview is the finished
product it's not like I'm just getting
sound bites for a report or a quotes
that I'm going to interpolate into a
written piece the interview is the thing
and so if I ask questions in a narrative
order I'm more likely to get an
interview with a narrative flow on the
other hand if I don't listen to what the
person saying then it's not going to be
much of an interview is it so it's a
it's a mix of what they're telling me
but I want to follow up on what it's
making me think of and and in the
structure I went in there with when are
you most nervous what kind of interviews
make you why you're actually doing them
make you the most nervous what makes me
the most nervous is one I feel I'm not
really prepared enough to to be equipped
to do the job I want to do and that
might be with an artist but it might
it's it's it it also might be with
something more political where I feel
like I need to be an expert on this
field you know that I don't really don't
necessarily know that much about and
I've studied I've crammed but I wish I
had like a week and not a night to
prepare for it so that makes you more
nervous than someone being a hostel for
instance I don't mind hostility that
might surprise people but it's good
radio you know I mean like like the gene
Simmons interview I always think that if
that interview had happened in
commercial radio my boss would say to me
now I want you to be that controversial
at least once a week this will be great
for the ratings no one ever says to me
be more controversial make people angry
because it's great for ratings and it is
I mean we've got a huge response to that
we've got a huge response when Bill
O'Reilly walked out it's great for
ratings so I don't I don't have anybody
insisting I do that just for ratings at
the same time when it does happen it's
interesting and I don't mind and it
challenges me as an interviewer I kind
of get a kick out of it
interesting
suddenly some of these are sort of
variations of what we've already talked
about um I'll say something else too
about you know we're talking ability and
Howard Stern the funny thing is like
when gene Simmons walked out on me if
gene Simmons had said on Howard Stern
Show something about if you want to
welcome me with open arms
not to Howard Stern obviously maybe to
Robin if you want to welcome you with
open arms you're lost I have to open me
welcome you with open legs
that doesn't make news on Howard Stern
Show it's fresh air it's news when two
people fight on public public radio is
so kind of you know civil and and you
know respectful and you know low-key in
that respect like when Bill O'Reilly you
know really goes after a guest on his
show
that's called business as usual but when
I asked him some challenging questions
and he walks out on me that makes news
cuz on my show on our show fresh air
it's it's not business as usual when
somebody's really angry or you know or
they start arguing with me like that so
you know just someone started singing
Kumbaya either occasionally a guest
turns the tables and asks you a question
what is that like does that throw you at
all um sometimes yeah sometimes I don't
answer it in part because I feel much
more comfortable in a setting like this
talking about myself
because this night is it's about me you
came here to see Frank Rich and to see
me but on the show it's not about me
it's about my guests and I feel like I
on my show I don't like the spotlight to
be on me I like it to be on the guest
our show isn't about me who is the very
formal sounding announcer on fresh air
what is she about the the most foremost
sounding announcer on formal sounding
formal sounding Oh II mean I sound more
formal on fresh air
no I it must be an announcer on the show
like introduces maybe the funding
credits
maybe it's the funding yeah okay that
they always sound formal because they're
they want your check our funding credits
if that is what you're talking about had
been read by our engineer or tree
Bentham could you give an overarching
theme of blue state values an
overarching theme of blue state values I
guess I guess whoever this questioner is
thinking is is thinking it sort of gets
back to what I was talking about earlier
about NPR being thought of as being oh
whatever
the blue state values exist in your view
and I don't like to think in those terms
I'll give you an example and this gets
back to what you're talking about before
about how the arts are affected in a
politicized time we happen to have on
you know a fair number of gay artists
for a lot of reasons first of all the
arts have always had a lot of gay people
in it the only difference is that you
know in the past couple of decades gay
artists have come out of the closet more
and more and therefore the subject of
their art can more comfortably be about
the truth of their lives which is that
it's going to be gay themed in a way
that it couldn't have been in the past
so you have on you know you have on gay
artists you're talking about you know
being gay or a gay life or a gay themed
memoir or a work of fiction or whatever
so the subject is gonna be gay right so
there was a period when and this this
has died down but there was a period
when we'd have gay artists on and we'd
get calls from program directors who
were angry saying look we you know we
have listeners calling in who think you
have too many gay guests on the show and
so you know I would say what would you
tell these people if they called up and
they said you know this is the third you
she's had on this week or you know this
is this is the fourth black person this
week you you wouldn't accept that and
even if it was creating a headache for
you you'd say well
you'd find a nice way of saying this is
not a good value this is this is this is
not a way to program you know you know
in other words just as anti-semitism and
racism is not a program a trait in your
listeners that you program to homophobia
should not be a trait in your listeners
that you program to and you find a nice
way to explain that for example if
people are playing accumulating there
too many Gators on you say what I just
said you know that that yeah hello
there's a lot of gay people in the arts
therefore there's a lot of gay artists
on the show you know gay people have
always been leaders in culture so
they're you know can they just drop your
show if they don't couple of stations to
drop us for that reason no this was
years ago but you know this kind of
thing is probably more pronounced though
it hasn't affected us as directly lately
and and and you know is that blue state
I don't know call it what you will but
it's another way that you know people
say is in peril liberal you know well we
do a lot of culture on the show and you
know again
the arts often go into territory that
some people might consider liberal you
know whether it's a gay memoir or again
talking about the dark parts of the
human soul that you know might be
difficult to talk about or to admit to
or to just to see in terms that aren't
unambiguously good and evil that kind of
gray area in between you know that's
either red nor blue it's gray last
question if you were interviewing Terry
Gross having done all the background
research you have done what question
might you ask to get the most surprising
answer
I'm incapable of answering that question
I could never interview myself I don't
think I have trouble interviewing
friends I always feel like I know so
much about them you know first of all it
you your curiosity is is kind of
satisfied in a way because you know a
lot about them and second of all I have
different it instinct when you know
somebody that you almost want to protect
them you want to protect them from the
spotlight and that's an instinct you
can't have when you're interviewing
somebody you have to just ask what you
think needs to be asked and not feel oh
this might make them uncomfortable and I
love them I don't wanna make them
uncomfortable you know so I understand
and I start I don't want to make myself
uncomfortable so I'll be interviewing
myself well in a comfortable note thank
you so much for being with us tonight
thank you for coming
all I did was ask is published by
Hyperion for more information visit
their website Hyperion Books calm
[Music]